this year fans everywhere have been
jonesing for some real quality superhero
movie content
gal gadot goddess that she is came to
provide
as promised the second trailer for
wonder woman 1984 debuted at the dc
fan dome event and is not all glitz and
flashy action like the first trailer for
the sequel movie was
there's even more substance this trailer
finally provides some much-wanted
details about kristen wiig's cheetah
including the first real glimpse at what
her transformation from archaeologist
barbara ann minerva into her villainous
alter ego looks like
along with that each character's
motivation is more clearly summarized in
the new trailer
wonder woman 1984 is obviously a film
meant to be more about clashing
personalities and dreams than about
saving the world or define the conquests
of gods like the first wonder woman was
back in 2017
it's narrower and more personal but that
doesn't mean the stakes aren't profound
here are some small details in the new
wonder woman 1984 trailer that you might
not have caught
and what they hint at for the movie at
large barbara
what did you do the ending of the first
wonder woman 1984 trailer released
during brazil's comic-con experience in
december 2019
appears to be the beginning of the
second trailer early on we see a simple
enough cut of a carrier helicopter
approaching a massive satellite receiver
on a small archipelago
the kicker comes later as the trailer
ends with the fight between diana
and the now fully transformed cheetah
there's little doubt this could be the
climactic final showdown between them
given the no holds barred sparring they
perform and the fact that diana is
donning her slick
upgraded golden armor but the point here
is that where the battle takes place
is the same location we see at the
beginning of the trailer you can tell
from the concrete aesthetic and lighting
as well as from a little bit of smaller
communications arrays that are briefly
seen
we don't know where this is yet of
course but it's probably the macguffin
of wonder woman 1984.
it's likely somehow related to whatever
nefarious plot that smarmy businessman
maxwell lord has
cheetah is acting as a flunky for him
throughout the story so what's so
critical about a satellite receiver that
she must be the last line of defense
against diana
it's been a while so it's understandable
if you don't remember but it looks like
we'll be seeing more than just diana's
mother queen hippolyta reprising an
amazonian role
during the opening scene of the trailer
which depicts a portion of the amazon
games
we see a long line of amazonian women
along with young diana
at the forefront of that line is someone
else we've seen before
venelia it's a surprising turn to see in
a flashback as we know vanilla goes on
to assist
diana's aunt and tayo in training diana
as a warrior
perhaps in these flashbacks incorporated
in wonder woman 1984 we'll get to see a
little bit more of diana's sisters in
arms and her relationships with them
and hopefully the sting of getting
bested by an eight-year-old during an
olympic style competition
won't last too long for vanilla the new
trailer also
finally gives us a peek into barbara ann
minerva's motivation as a villain
jealousy
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
it upends the presentation of her
relationship with diana in the first
1984 trailer as being pretty friendly
what everything seems to mean to barbara
more than beauty or money is status and
confidence
to quote the woman herself i want to be
an apex predator
the scene in which diana exits a
limousine all eyes turn to her
and some swanky gala is immediately
followed by a sequence of barbara
walking into that same event
while others look her up and down with
obvious reluctance to approach
we know barbara is an archaeologist and
colleague of diana's
but little else is confirmed about the
movie's take on the character
what could cause her to be so ostracized
from her professional community and
create all this hostility that she
eventually unleashes on diana
despite diana's attempts to befriend her
a slightly less subtle small detail
present are the parallels between
young diana prince and adult diana
prince
it happens right at the trailer's outset
as young diana is participating in the
amazon games alongside her sisters
we watch as the tiny warrior sprints
with all her might
surpassing her competitors with an
expression of determination on her face
that's spliced with footage of adult
diana racing down a city street
making the exact same face her younger
self did all those years ago
then as kid diana bolts up the curved
edges of the oval amphitheater pumping
her
arms through the air and finally leaping
into the open air beyond the dome
we see adult diana slicing the city air
with her gauntleted arms and then
swinging her lasso of truth before
flinging herself into space it's a
compelling bit of parallelism and
possibly hints that wonder woman 1984
will be digging deeper into diana's
upbringing to show how she became the
superhero she is today
you're stronger than you believe you
have greater powers than you know
it seems that somewhere in the course of
the movie maxwell lord will basically
wish himself into the white house with
the mysterious artifact that gives
barbara her powers
and lets diana have her long lost love
steve trevor back
in the first trailer for the film lord's
big overture to the world about giving
them what they want is
filmed over a diamond themed background
in another scene from the trailer we see
magical gusts buffeting the artifact as
lord performs
some supernatural act perhaps he grants
the whole world's wishes to gain
legitimacy as president
the new trailer includes lord's speech
as well but the broadcast takes place
over several computer monitors
and plays out over the airwaves as
citizens hang on to lord's every word
with curious confusion
it's also clear that it's happening from
the white house briefing room
later we see cheetah and wonder woman
fighting in the actual white house
and the men attacking diana are almost
certainly secret service as well as
capitol police
finally we have a shot of barbara and
lord on air force one discussing evil
plans
and you can see the embroidered seal of
the presidential office on lord's seat
this is a sizable twist from what we
understood from the original trailer
we were initially led to believe lord
was simply a billionaire businessman
which provides plenty of power all on
its own as tears for fears wisely
counseled in 1985
everybody wants to rule the world but
what does more
mean for max lord if the seat of
american power isn't enough
we can't wait to find out when wonder
woman 1984 takes flight october 2nd
2020 check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one